vers nouvelle arnaque sur internet des
clients de deux banques se sont aperçus
que des inconnus avaient eu accès à leur
compte bancaire via le net
quinze mille euros ont ainsi été
ponctionnés sur le compte des victimes
enquête vincent fourcade est jeune ça mc
une série de chiffres
puis un code en principe secret il n'en
faut pas davantage pour prendre à
distance le contrôle du compte bancaire
d'un tiers placement virement tous les
mouvements d'argent deviennent alors
possible un rêve pour tous les escrocs
deux clients de la société générale
viennent de faire les frais d'une telle
arnaque sur internet
quinze mille euros volés
électroniquement d'un simple clic de
souris une inconnue comment les escrocs
ont ils pu pirater ses comptes une
certitude sur internet
la méfiance est de rigueur on reçoit un
mail
apparemment de sa banque lui demandant
de se connecter sur un lien pour par
exemple est resté c'est parler de
connexion ce qui va faire et sans s'en
rendre compte il va amener toutes les
informations le mécanisme est simple sur
internet
un conte est piraté et son contenu virée
sur celui d'un complice en france il n'a
plus qu'à se rendre à sa banque faire un
retrait d'espèces avant d'envoyer le
tout à l'étranger grâce à des mandats
les cerveaux de l'opération court
toujours
deux de leurs complices français sont
maintenant derrière les barreaux quant
aux victimes
à elles de prouver qu'elles ont bien été
l'objet d'une arnaque dans ce genre
d'escroquerie il est souvent très
difficile pour les clients d'un amené la
preuve donc il faudra que les banques en
question puisqu'il s'agit d'une faute à
elle de sécurisation ne pose pas de
problème dans remboursement des clients
une enquête est maintenant en cours pour
connaître l'origine exacte de la fraude
mais les banques assurent déjà que leurs
sites de gestion en ligne ne souffrirait
d'aucune faille sécuritaire